a pleasant midsummer night in boston
temperatures in the high 70s as the new
york yankees rolled into town for the
first of a four-game series this weekend
against the red sox the first place
boston red sox as we welcome you to
fenway park the grand dam of the
american league home to the red sox
since 1912. and they're going to face
tanner houck
this guy's quite a story the one draft
pick from
a few years ago he started four games
record oh and two this year but if you
go back a couple years
this lights out for
three years for three games rather for
the red sox so uh he's got electric
stuff
facing a tough lead off hitter lamia's
been reach-based 31 straight in the air
to right renfro backs up and takes it
well here's a guy that his numbers may
not look outstanding but he loves this
ballpark stanton hit hard to center
field [ __ ] hernandez on the move but he
takes it one two three inning for tanner
howe there you see jordan montgomery the
lanky lefty
18 starts record little deceptive
yankees haven't scored
many runs for him
the former dodger is at 241 with 14 home
runs
in the air to center field his floreal
might have misjudged it
nearly colliding
with greg allen coming over from right
field but it's floreal who makes the
grab moment he broke back a step
boy that's great communication i mean
you can imagine what a collision that
could be and you're talking about
two guys now maybe they played next to
one another in the minor leagues
probably but you have to have good
communication on a play like that to
avoid a coalition last sunday night in
the bronx
he had a bunt single and a two-run homer
against the red sox and lines it safely
they hadn't shifted on him but he found
a spot
and it's a lead-off single first hit of
the night for either club
broke one bat and then didn't get this
one in quite far enough not right on the
barrel but got enough of it to get it
into right field for a base hit
and now gleber torres struck him
out of the chase
second strike out of the mountain most
strikeouts end up being pitches out of
the strike zone and there's that
sweeping
now people would say that's a slider
it's not really a slider is a small
breaking pitch but that's a slurvey fast
curve and here is rob brentley and
bradley strikes out
second in a row three and an inning in
two thirds for howard
you may remember him from a stint in
cleveland also in san diego
got him looking three strikeouts after a
lead off single for modora renfro the
former tampa bay ray is hitting as you
see 260 with power 15 homers wax this
one into right center field and floreal
comes on
for a shoestring catch montgomery with a
nod of appreciation as an outfielder do
i dive or not and floriel could see that
hey with those long limbs he could reach
down make the catch right off
the top of the turf we mentioned tanner
houck's cleats it's a cause near and
dear to his heart he started a
foundation called pitch for adoption
where every strikeout donates 100 to the
kirita's family's solutions
a child services organization came in
hitting 2-7
he's a career 302 hitter and so too is
the performance of tanner hauck
that is his sixth strikeout so now after
retiring the first six
montgomery faces his first jam we do go
at third chapus at first
he did not montgomery gets the strikeout
when he needs it now devers
among the major league leaders in rbis
with 74.
he holds off and the bases are loaded
and that's a tough take but he
definitely checked muster an angle there
counting your strikeout in the first
bogartz is nine for 20 in his career
against montgomery with the bases loaded
caught and shortstop by tauros they
leave him loaded we played three second
consecutive walk issued by house to
start the fourth hadn't walked anybody
through three this one gets by vasquez
and the yankee runners move up gardner
to third and stanton to second score it
as a pass ball at shortstop bogarts
it'll score a run
and the yankees take the lead gartner
comes across
rbi for torres and a damaging pass ball
if you get that same ball off the bat of
torres right at bogart's that's an
ending ending double play but it rained
so hard
before they stopped play that it took a
long time for them to get the field back
into something close to playable you see
how it looks right here before the delay
and then the grounds crew went to work
it looked like military precision kind
of like the army corps of engineers with
the job that they did but
you saw the reflection of the water on
the infield i'm told that this is an
engineered infield tyler wade who had
reached on an infield hit is it first
with two out here in the yankee fifth
and a two out walk so first and second
with brett gardner coming to the plate
struck out and then walked and scored
if montgomery gives boone six innings
and concludes this inning with a
one-nothing lead i think aaron would be
happy with that
hits it through the right side for a
two-out single montgomery will not make
it through the six sal romano is coming
in the single by martinez greets romano
fly ball to right
and allen
tucks it away
the red sox leave two as renfro was
retired now a chance for chavis singled
and
fielder's choice e5 litke is going to
stay in to face [ __ ] hernandez
lifted into shallow right center field
allen
[Applause]
tags comes to the plane and scores
and verdugo in a one-nothing game
tags and scores so the play that tyler
wade almost made
but ultimately couldn't looms large
adevino comes in
walks la mayhew who then steals second
then gardner walks and up comes stanton
stanton lines it into left center field
and it drops
two walks at an rbi single two one yanks
gonna bring the infield in
in
to make a nice catch
gardner tags and scores and it's 3-1 new
york the tying runs are aboard
well here's the hitter that's been their
miracle man
[Applause]
hernandez has driven home all three red
sox runs gardner now with the infield in
the runner at third
a fly ball to left center field that's
going to get the job done verdugo to the
edge of the track
he scores and for the moment the yankees
regain the lead
i can only imagine in fenway park nine
innings of experience such an important
game for the
[Applause]
wild
yankees
and a walk mixed in
and now the winning run is 90 feet away
this is the game right here
allen retreats almost no chance
yanks are on the verge of closing to
within six
instead they fall eight back